u.s and china have entered a cold war
style standoff
cooperation on multiple fronts is an
all-time low
and one could assume the movie business
is no exception
after all why should hollywood pander to
beijing hollywood now
regularly censors its own movies to
appease the chinese communist
party the world's most powerful violator
of human rights even the u.s state
secretary mike pompeo was scathing in a
recent speech
hollywood not too far from here the epic
center of american creative freedom
and self-appointed arbiters of social
justice
self-censors even the most mildly
unfavorable reference
to china so is it really worth it well
turns out
it is last year china contributed 9.2
billion dollars to the global box office
that's almost a quarter of global movie
ticket sales
while hollywood may have limited access
to the chinese market
viewing figures from asia can often make
or break a movie
and the bank
this is the way the world ends
[Music]
but to get its hands on a slice of the
money pie hollywood needs to tread
carefully
china is a tough client despite having
the second
largest film market in the world beijing
is protective
allowing only around 40 foreign movies
per year
so hollywood has to compromise to fill
all the slots
but we all know that he who pays the
piper calls the tune
the u.s lets china call the shots when
it comes to the
fine detail in movies this could be
portraying the chinese
as the good guys think 2012 or gravity
to make our way to the space station
over there
i said that the government is building
these ships
nasa rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking mutiny
if anything goes wrong cutting out
offensive taiwanese flags from the top
gun sequel
or making sure key characters aren't of
tibetan origin
beijing could simply cancel the release
of a movie deemed offensive
tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood was scrapped
apparently because of the portrayal of
bruce lee we get into a fight i
accidentally kill you
i go to jail the upcoming milan movie
has had a kissing scene cut to avoid a
similar fate
some even speculate that actors who
displeased beijing
disappeared from the really big screen
apparently richard gere got too friendly
with the dalai lama
and two involved in supporting tibet no
more movies with him in china
perhaps he could be replaced with a
chinese counterpart after all more
chinese actors are being hired
to satisfy the growing demand all
is as the force wills
evolution
[Music]
what is your name soldier paging
commander son of hojo
we're going to make men out of every
single one of you
the trump administration has been moving
away from the current order with their
stand up to china slogan but there's a
little alternative
how can there be when even global giants
like apple
have to play by china's rules to have
market access so it's unlikely hollywood
will change anytime
soon when it comes to choosing between
politics and profit
the film industry will pick the latter
every time
after all show business is just that a
business